okay take me back let's say
hypothetically I'm an independent rapper
I happen to be a drug dealer I got
stupid money money's not a problem right
I'm a rapper in 2004 2005. and I'm like
yo I hit up convict music and I'm like I
need the Akon special I need the song I
need the hook I need everything right
what do you hit me upside the head for
200 000. 200 000. now does that increase
if it's a major label it's 200 000 with
this major or not wow 200k the price
didn't change plus you get your Pub oh
yeah I mean you get everything you're
supposed to get that's just for our
services that's amazing 200k so you're
doing a lot of those oh we did a lot of
those what was the busiest year you had
the busiest year was oh I mean years the
busiest years was from 2005 to 2009. wow
five good years that's crazy yep yeah
you had it man did you ever hear that
from radios programmers they complained
everyone I went to I mean I remember
they had created even this I don't know
if it was a law but it was the system it
was whatever you're about to say it was
a real thing I didn't know because like
an acorn rule right they were like okay
you can't play uh I want to say my
records Akon and T-Pain you can't yeah
you can't play it was 100 a thing right
oh I didn't even know that because
they're because because back in the day
there used to be artist separation when
people would program the logs for a
radio station and at one point in time
it was you and pain and then once the
Wayne [ __ ] really took off it kind of
all intersected and then it was like
there's no way this is possible we can't
it just didn't make sense and then
[ __ ] T-Pain and Wayne around got
money together and that's just a double
[ __ ] you to program directors because
it's like how do we program this [ __ ]
song they're both on it it's crazy it
was [ __ ] crazy man